cette semaine comment les autochtones
voit les non autochtones qui viennent
travailler dans leur communauté
oui bienvenue à paroles autochtone 6 et
mélissa mollen dupuis cette semaine je
réponds à la question de sabrina avec un
très gros attention parce que on peut
pas généraliser sur l'opinion des gens
des communautés et sur l'expérience
vécue par les non autochtones qui
viennent à et communautés ça va être
très changeant selon la communauté dans
laquelle la personne va aller travailler
est très changeant aussi selon
l'individu qui va aller travailler dans
une communauté
je peux cependant partager certaines des
expériences ou des observations combat
partagé par le passé sur justement
l'expérience d'aller dans une communauté
travailler il ya deux mentalités très
distincts et qui vont faire la
différence quand tu rentres travailler
dans une communauté
la première c'est quand tu vois la
mentalité du sauveur je vais travailler
dans une communauté autochtone tu veux
les aider tu veux changer leur monde de
la solution
ils vont ils vont profiter des lumières
c'est souvent une manière d'approcher
des communautés qui peuvent résulter
dans des expériences très positive ça
soit en fait que les gens vont se sentir
isolé par la communauté parce que
justement la communauté va peut-être pas
est ouverte à l'idée de voir quelqu'un
arrivé en sauveur vouloir leur dire
comment ils font pour les affaires alors
qu'ils ont une preuve de bonne idée des
enjeux qui les touchent
puisque ça fait des années qu'ils sont
dans ces enjeux de et qui sont à la
recherche justement d'une solution mais
d'une solution qui viendraient 2 et non
pas de l'extérieur parce que les
solutions de l'extérieur on a eu
beaucoup et ça ne crée quand même les
réserves des pensionnats donc c'est un
des types de mentalité qui n'est pas une
très grande réussite
celle qu'on me partage etc en était une
c'est quand tu rentres dans la
communauté comme tel est rentré dans un
village où aller travailler dans un
poste à trois-rivières suivants parce
que tu veux vivre l'expérience d'aller
dans une communauté qui est différente
tu arrives l'esprit ouvert le cas ouvert
à vivre de nouvelles expériences
certaines expériences peuvent être
négative certaines petites expériences
sont extrêmement positives et certaines
expériences sont pourra jamais vivre à
alors que dans les communautés
autochtones donc je pense que c'est la
même chose que quelqu'un qui viendrait
et qui déménagerait à montréal certaines
expériences négatives dont un positives
et d'autres ne pourront jamais être
vécues ailleurs qu'à montréal donc
garder ça en tête
c'est vraiment la différence que j'ai vu
par le passé en quelqu'un qui part au
bout d'un an est quelqu'un qui reste qui
marie quelqu'un de la communauté qui
fait des enfants qui finalement est
intégré complètement dans la communauté
et dans mon amour avec le territoire je
pense que ça fait vraiment une
différence énorme c'est pas tant quelle
communauté choisir quelle personne tu es
sait vraiment comment tu arrives dans la
communauté la première expérience du
début j'ai d'ailleurs une lecture a
suggéré d'alexandra chimot and the bone
of honor invisible une lecture qui est
quand même très courte mais qui montre
quand même l'expérience de quelqu'un qui
arrive des fois avec des idées
préconçues et qui vit des choses qui
dont il ne s'attendait pas du tout à
vivre dans une communauté du nord donc
recommander chaudement à lire pour ceux
qui s'intéressent je m'en aille
travailler dans les autres communautés
j'espère avoir répondu à ta question
sabrina j'espère que vous y serez pas
nous envoyer d'autres questions a
demandé autour de vous justement qu'elle
a été l'expérience de vie dans la
communauté à faire la distinction
justement les deux les deux même genre
de mentalité dans laquelle la personne
est allé dans la communauté
il n'était pas à partager des vidéos et
surtout prenez soin de vous une belle
semaine de la part de l'uci de l'équipe
de parole autochtone